la fin d'un symbole la tente dressée par
la coordination des infirmières devant
le ministère de la santé a été démonté
aujourd'hui la fin d'un des plus longs
sit in de l'histoire 1470 jours pour
attirer l'attention des pouvoirs publics
sur les conditions de travail des
infirmières patrice volée et didier da
le dernier carré des protestataires une
vingtaine d'infirmiers et d'infirmières
venu le vélo quand comme maryse présente
depuis le premier jour pour elle cette
tante symboliser le mouvement infirmiers
des années 90 91
les premières grèves d'une profession
trop peu reconnue plier bagage
aujourd'hui ne s'est pas fait sans
émotion
g
nouveau
pas du tout on se servira que je peux
pour deux
vêtu de méchant
dressant les ensembles réformes pro fini
chaque mois depuis plus de quatre ans
maryse venait de daxas parle permanence
sous la tente réunion syndicale des
jours loin de sa famille avec toujours
la même volonté améliorer la politique
de santé du pays
c'était très difficile beaucoup de
fatigue eu beaucoup de
d'investissement d'énergie personnel
d'enfants
mais à la fois
j'ai continué parce que pour moi c'était
porteur de
devenir mai
et cet objectif s'est avéré difficile
quinze jours après l'installation les
canons à eau répondait aux manifestants
depuis huit ministres de la santé se
sont succédé des artistes ont soutenu le
mouvement
ils l'ont oublié au bilan de la
coordination quelques avancées
salariales bien peu de créations de
postes et un record au guinness book la
plus longue occupation d'un trottoir
il est ce soir décorée aux couleurs des
infirmières leur dernier clin d'oeil au
ministère de la santé juste en face